[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Dan Olshansky.
I'm an intern here on the
Android team at Google.
And today, I'll be talking about
some ListView animation
insertions.
So in this specific demo, what
we're going to be doing is
adding a new object to the
zeroth index of the data set
associated with the ListView,
and then animating that cell
downwards into it.
As that's going to happen, all
the other items in the
ListView are going to make
space for the new cell,
animate downwards as the new
cell animates back in.
And then, just as a cool little
extra part to the
animation, we're going to have
an image that's part of the
cell animate into its correct
location as the new element is
being added to it.
Some of the important things
to know for this animation,
some of the few tricks and
problems I encountered, is the
fact that when you change the
data set, some of the objects
that you may need may no longer
be available after the
layout has occurred.
So what you need to do is you
need to take a snapshot of all
the items before you modify the
data set so that after you
modify the data set, if you no
longer have a reference to
some of these items, you can
still animate them out of the
bounds of the list view, because
you won't need them
after that anymore.
So jumping straight into the
demo, all we have here is a
button, little round
view to its left.
The list is completely empty.
Clicking Add Row--
Animate creates a new cell and
animates it downwards.
And we can add as many
elements as you want.
Those start looping.
And as you can see, it
animates downwards.
And all the elements in ListView
underneath animate
down as that happens.
You can now of course scroll
the list if you want to.
But the interesting thing to
note as well is that even
though each of these images
is part of the data set
associated with that item in the
list with that exact cell,
what we're doing is animating
the image from outside the
bounds of the ListView into its
correct location in the
ListView, where it then stays
and persists as you scroll the
list here afterwards.
So then, looking at the code,
we can go into Insertion
ListView, which is an object
that extends ListView where
you can insert these
new items.
And after a lot of other applied
code that you can look
over later, all the main logic
happens in Add Row.
So firstly, what we need to do
here is first get a reference
for an adapter.
And afterwards, what I'm going
to do is keep track of the
balance and the drawables of all
the items that are in my
ListView before the data
set change took place.
So I'm going to loop through
all of my visible cells.
And I'm going to take a screen
shot of every single cell.
I'm going to store that.
I'm also going to retrieve the
balance of every single cell
and store that in a
corresponding hash map as well.
So now, regardless of whether
or not those cells are still
there after data set change has
taken place, I'll still
have a reference to them.
Then, when you move down here,
I actually add the new object
to my data set and
add this table ID
corresponding to that item.
Because in my array adapter,
I've specified
true for stable IDs.
So that means I need to make
sure that a new stable ID is
added to that element.
Then, I notifyDataSetChanged,
which will request a layout on
behalf of the ListView.
But since I want this to
animate, one of the common
tricks that have been used for
a lot of these animations is
using an onPreDrawListener.
So once again, onMeasure and
onLayout Layout have already
been called.
All the final values for all the
widgets contained within
the ListView have already been
calculated but have not been
drawn to the screen yet.
So this is where any custom
animations you want to do you
can do them here since you
already have a reference to
all the final values.
So going into onPreDraw, we
remove the listener and create
a new array list where we're
going to store all our
animations.
So firstly, since I know that
I'm adding a new cell to the
zeroth index, that's the view
that I'm going to want to use
for a lot of my calculations
and animations.
And then, what I'm creating is
creating a copy ImageView,
because I can't actually animate
the view that I need
from within the cells, from
outside the bounds, and put it
where I need to.
But what I'm going to do is
create a new copy ImageView
that has the same
content as the
ImageView in the cell itself.
Then, I'll just animate it into
place and then get rid of
it when I don't need
it anymore.
So when I'm animating a new row,
one of the other things I
do is just animate the text
associated with that cell,
fade it in as it
animates down.
And in regards to the image,
there's some math that I need
to do to determine where
it starts and
where it has to end.
But after all that is done, all
you need to really know is
that the ImageView in the cell
has to be set to invisible
while the animation is
happening, while the copy
ImageView has to be visible.
I use an overshoot interpolator
and scale the x
and the y properties of the
image just to get this little
cool popping-like effect.
And then, I animate it into
place in the new cell view.
And once that's done, I can
later at the end do animation
and get rid of my copy
ImageView and set the
visibility of my normal
view back to normal.
So scrolling down
furthermore--
this is once the data
set change has
already been modified.
So then, I'll loop through all
my visible children of the
ListView at this point.
And there are going to be two
types of children that I'll be
working with, those that have a
corresponding balance in the
hash map [INAUDIBLE] originally
and those that don't.
If they do have a corresponding
balance, then
what that means is that they
were visible in the ListView
before the animation, and
they're also visible in the
ListView after the animation.
So all I need to do is create
an object animator that
translates it from its old
position to its new position.
If I don't have that start
balance, then what that means
is that in the context of this
demo, there's only one cell
that can have this
configuration.
It means that it wasn't in the
ListView before, but it is in
the ListView after.
And since we're only inserting
one new item into the
ListView, this has to be the
one in the zeroth index.
And since I also want to animate
this, I do a little
bit of math in determining what
the height is, what the
divider height is.
And then, I do the same thing
and animate its transition y
property to get it from where it
originally would have been
to where I want it to
be after the layout.
And then of course, since I
don't need these others
anymore, I remove them
from my hash map.
And then, scrolling down here,
if I loop through a key set of
all the items that are left in
my hash map, what this means
is that these are items that
were in the ListView prior to
the data set change but are no
longer visible in the ListView
after the data set change.
So these involve items that have
been moved outside the
bounds of the ListView due to
the insertion of the new item.
And since these items are no
longer contained within the
ListView container, what I need
to do is use the bitmap
drawables, which I've captured
from before, overlay them on
top of my ListView, and then
animate their bounds as if
they were still in
the ListView.
Since I'm animating the bounds,
it's important to know
that every single time the
bounds are changed, I need to
invalidate my view in order
for that portion of the
ListView to get updated.
And in order to make that a
little more efficient, I call
Invalidate with [INAUDIBLE]
of it such that I don't
re-invalidate the whole
ListView and redraw the whole
thing every single time only
one of the bitmap drawables
has animated.
So I set up those animations
for every bitmap drawable.
And I also add it to this
array that I have
mCellBitmapDrawables, which I
will make note of in a second.
And I add the animation
to my animator set.
I animate all this together.
And then at the end, I do all
the default things like make
my ListView enabled again,
make the ImageView in the
actual cell visible again,
make the copy imagery
invisible, and things
like that.
So now, here in dispatchDraw,
this is where I'm going to use
that array of all the bitmap
drawables corresponding to the
items that disappeared.
I'm going to loop through all of
them and draw them onto the
canvas every single time
dispatchDraw is called.
One of the important things to
note here is that I'm checking
the size is zero just to make
sure that there are no extra
locations done using the new
Java object for loops.
And scrolling down furthermore,
there's just some checks.
I'm checking whether I want
to animate in the
new image or not.
So for example, if I were to
scroll down here and then add
a row, I'm not at the top, so
I'm not going to be animating
in that image.
Whereas if I'm up here, the new
ImageView will be animating.
Down here, there's just some
more code of how I'm taking
snapshots of the ListView cells
and how I animate them
into place, as well as how I'm
getting absolute locations on
the screen when I want to know
where that extra ImageView
needs to be when I decide
where to animate it to.
So that's pretty much it to how
you can insert new cells
and animate their addition
to your ListView---
thanks.